elle est jolie elle a commencé au cinéma
très jeune elle aurait pu faire une
carrière facile les au fil des films où
on a découvert un caractère une
personnalité qui s'affirme doucement
mais sûrement voici maintenant l'invité
mais cinq dernières minutes et s'est
invitée c'est virginie ledoyen
bonjour virginie merci d'être avec nous
sur le plateau du 13 heures de france 2
pour parler d'un film très réussi
un baiser s'il vous plaît d'emmanuel
mouret on ne va pas raconter toute
l'histoire mais en écoutant le titre un
baiser s'il vous plaît on a déjà un
indice
oui on a on alain 10 d'une histoire
d'amour de deux personnes qui vont se
retrouver confrontés à leurs actes à
leurs désirs et ça passera par un baiser
elle reste que ce baiser va être une
grande histoire d'amour ou ou est-ce que
ce serait anodin alors en fait ce baiser
il va avoir lieu entre vous julie
nicolas qui est votre meilleur ami
au début c'est plutôt anodin parce que
c'est plutôt vous voulez lui rendre
service
oui c'est ça c'est en fait elle je joue
un jeune scientifique marié plutôt très
heureuse dans son couple et son meilleur
ami et comme il le dit très bien ou
d'affections physiques et comme elle est
très très serviable elle va lui rendre
service et malheureusement ou
heureusement ils vont être très
bouleversée par atar ce baiser et sur
ses conséquences
alors qu'il y est très agréable pour
vous dans sims et que votre personnage
il évolue beaucoup au fur et à mesure du
film au début vous êtes jeune femme un
peu bourgeoise très rangée et puis au
fur et à mesure on sent un peu la folie
et l'amour pire ans et qui transforme
votre personnalité et l'histoire oui
mais c'est ça qui me plaisait c'est que
je trouvais que emmanuel se sert de de
code comme ça et de gens qui ont l'air
très très rangée et en fait des gens
très libre et très transgressif et en
même temps avec une espèce de civilité
et de et de soucis des autres qui je
trouve à même de la fantaisie du et de
la comédie et du burlesque aux propos
way est un joli regard aussi sûr
l'histoire amoureuse parce que c'est
joli ce qui se dit dans ce film
oui ce qu'il dit c'est qu'on n'est pas
mettre toujours de cézac août et que et
que parfois l'amour pour vous surprendre
alors est ce que est ce qu'on est ce
qu'on se laisse tenter et où quelqu'un
comment on fait pour pour que les gens
souffrent le moins possible alors on va
tout de suite voir un extrait du film on
à peu près au milieu de l'histoire et on
se rend compte justement que l'histoire
entre julie et nicolas est loin d'être
un simple arrangement amical on regarde
ensemble en vie s'il faut que je fasse
l'amour avec la hauteur ce soir ça fait
trop longtemps
pourquoi tu fais ça tu es tu t'es jaloux
un peu je pense à toi comme ça c'est
comme s'ils se trouvaient pas t'es
jaloux
oui mais je comprends moi moi aussi ça
me permettra de faire l'amour à kalin ce
soir il sans trop avoir mauvaise
conscience ça allait faire l'amour c'est
ça il faut bien puisque tu veux pas que
je la quitte
non si on ne veut pas que tu la quittes
je veux pas que ça vaut recèle comme moi
le singe retrouve claudio jusqu'à papili
serait trop fait savoir à bourg
d'honneur je le suis pas oui mais je
crois que je serai mieux sol gelé kevin
était quelqu'un de très bien
c'est justement parce que c'est
quelqu'un de très bien que je
culpabilise le palais mais comme il faut
elles méritent mieux que ça mérite mais
qu'est ce que je suis alors c'est une
comédie drôle légère très agréable à
regarder ce qui est agréable aussi c'est
qu'il ya pas un rebondissement toutes
les 20 secondes comme il peut y avoir
dans des comédies il ya une certaine
lenteur dans ce film en tout cas on
prend le temps de connaître ces gens de
de les écouter les entendre et on leur
laisse le temps d'exister sur tous deux
de se coltiner à ce qui leur arrive
donc ça changerait emmanuel mouret c'est
vraiment un réalisateur à part dans le
cinéma françaises que c'est ce qui vous
a donné envie de participer à ce film
vous travailler avec lui oui bien sûr
parce que je trouve qu'il est très
atypique il est
le metteur en scène scénariste est
également acteur de ce film est il un
univers qui est qui est proche de signer
à ce que j'aime beaucoup comme mondiale
n comme rohmer comme comme alain resnais
comme et je trouve que pour un jeune
homme de 35 ans et les les singuliers
alors je t'arrête de votre carrière pour
vous présenter parce qu'elle est assez
singulière il ya des jeunes actrices
comme vous ayant commencé cinéma très
tôt qui ont très vite envie de
multiplier les films de faire beaucoup
de choses vous donnera l'impression
al'inverse que vous prenez le temps je
oui enfin en tout cas c'est vrai que
comme j'ai commencé très jeune j'étais
assez gâté et en même temps j'ai eu très
tôt la chance de rencontrer des tétées
des cinéastes qui m'ont et donner envie
d'être actrice est permis de l'être donc
ça donne une exigence et mais vous
n'avez pas peur du vide
non j'ai pas peur du vide excusez moi je
tousse
non j'ai pas peur du vide parce que
parce que j'aime ce que je fais et que
je trouve que que que faire un film
c'est y adhérer vraiment donc donc j'ai
pas je suis pas boulimique de travail
j'aime bien ça mais j'aime bien vivre
aussi et ça me permet de réalimenter le
désir d'ailleurs est alors maintenant
savourer réussit très bien parce que
vous participez à des films très
différents les uns des autres
comment on passe par exemple d'un film
comme la plage superproduction avec des
acteurs européens mais aussi américains
à des films beaucoup plus intimiste à
des comédies françaises
c'est cette diversité là aussi qui vous
construit j'imagine oui mais parce que
c'est d'abord mon goût de spectatrice
est vrai que je gêne des choses très
différentes au cinéma et et que je
trouve que que le grand luxe d'un acteur
c'est pouvoir se balader dans des
univers très différents donc donc
d'alterner pas pour chercher le
contre-emploi systématiquement parce que
c'est ce que moi j'aime voir au cinéma
donc c'est ce que j'aime faire
merci à vous virginie ledoyen et
recommande chaudement ce film donc il
sort aujourd'hui en salles un baiser
s'il vous plaît d'emmanuel mouret avec
virginie ledoyen bien sûr julie gayet
stefano accorsi c'est un très joli film
vraiment merci à vous d'être aux micros